will say Andrew Tate had a valid
criticism saying yes that Islam does not
tolerate the current state of the United
States now I've said this in the that is
true if you're talking about the Quran
and Islam not tolerating drag queen
Story Hour right I get it you have a
point that's misinterpretation of what
we were discussing what I was saying was
that the Quran is incompatible with the
First Amendment so not what we are
living out in the United States today
which I get I don't want to export this
culture right now American culture was a
great thing to bring to the rest of the
world when it involved Freedom right
when we were judeo Christian Nation so
that's a valid point from Andrew Tate
what I am saying is go back to the
founders and the Quran is certainly not
compatible with the First Amendment with
the Second Amendment you think Jews and
Christians are going to be allowed to
have guns under Sharia law for they have
a curfew dimude and a pole tax so I just
want to be clear his criticism there is
one that a lot of people make regarding
the Western world today where for the
first time we are on the wrong side
morally culturally of history that has
nothing to do with the Quran being
incompatible with the founding documents